je suis devenu une bataille gaye parce
que mes parents se sont fait braquer et
tué en sortant de l'eau gras je vous
avais dit que salle ty avait vidé leurs
cartes de crédit sur des sites
pornographiques
j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion de
croiser ce gars et quatre matins pour
que je mette son esprit en lévitation au
dessus de son corps si pas vrai marty
mais si tu est sur d'avoir inconnu
d'avoir un je ne sais pas qui tu parles
je connais aucun amour qu aucun nouveau
était de 2,9 à c'est moi dave pour
coutume biyong parce que je suis qui
casse vous connaissez les genres depuis
l'âge de 5 ans c'est quoi ces conneries
à propos de tes parents assassinés
c'est quoi ce langage quoi va-t-elle
gaye tu peux revoir ton cv